elle est là elle vient de plonger c'est
une terminent n ça on l'appelle
familièrement l'hirondelle de mer un
oiseau venus d'afrique reconnaissable à
sa calotte noire et son vol élégant
avoir listé renée y en a plein dans le
monde
il y en a des très gros sur les très
petites elles ont toutes la
particularité d'être migratrices et là
sur la cette portion de loire à orléans
nous avons la sterne pierregarin qui est
rouge du bec et aux pattes rouges et sa
cousine la sterne naine qui a des bêtes
jaune et pas de jaune au total trois
colonies de sternes ont élu domicile sur
les îlots de sable dupont tina et ses
environs une population de près de 250
individus qui niche à même le sol
ce sont des oiseaux qui ne font pas de
nid qui ce qui pose simplement les oeufs
sur le caillou sur le gravier d'où
l'importance d'éviter de marcher sur ses
landes ses langues de sable puisque à
tout moment on peut écraser ou déranger
une niche et espèce protégée au niveau
national et européen
les sternes font l'objet d'une vaste
campagne de protection
c'est l'état qui prend des arrêtés mais
il ya également un certain nombre de
choses à faire notamment posé des
pancartes comme on le fait faire de
l'information au public
les habitants sont priés de ne pas s'en
approcher
afin que la nature est pour tous un
objet d'émerveillement